one of the most important ways to calm
down
is the power to hold on even in
challenging situations
to a distinction between what someone
does
and what they meant to do in law the
difference is enshrined in the
contrasting concepts of
murder and manslaughter the result may
be the same
the body is inert in a pool of blood but
we collectively feel it makes a huge
difference
what the perpetrator's intentions were
motives
are crucial but unfortunately we're
seldom very good at perceiving what
motives happen to be involved
in the incidents that frustrate us we're
easily
and wildly mistaken we see intention
where there was none
and escalate and confront when no
strenuous or agitated responses are in
fact warranted
part of the reason why we jump so
readily to dark conclusions
and see plots to insult and harm us is a
rather poignant psychological phenomenon
self-hatred the less we like ourselves
the more we appear in our own eyes as
really rather plausible targets for
mockery and harm
why would a drill have started up
outside just as we were settling down to
work
why did the email not arrive even though
we'll have to be in a meeting very soon
why would the phone operator be taking
so long to find our details
because there is logically enough a plot
against us
because we're appropriate targets for
these kinds of things
because with the sort of people against
whom disruptive drilling
is legitimately likely to be directed
it's what we deserve
when we carry a background excess of
self-disgust around with
us operating just below the radar of
conscious awareness
will constantly seek confirmation from
the wider world
that we really are the worthless people
we take ourselves to be
the expectation is almost always set in
childhood
where someone close to us is likely to
have left us feeling dirty and culpable
and as a result we now travel through
society assuming the worst
not because it's necessarily true or
pleasant to do so
but because it feels familiar and
because we're the prisoners of past
patterns
we haven't yet understood we'd be so
much calmer around adults
if we could resort to some of the
unflusted poise we naturally use
around children small children sometimes
behave in really maddening ways
they scream at the person who's looking
after them angrily push away a bowl of
animal pasta
throw away something you've just fetched
for them but we rarely feel
personally agitated or wounded by their
behavior
and the reason is that we don't assign a
negative motive or mean intention
to a small person we reach around for
the most benevolent interpretations
we probably think that they're just a
bit tired or their gums are sore
or they're upset by the arrival of a
younger sibling we've got a large
repertoire of alternative explanations
ready in our heads and none of these
leaders to panic or
get terribly agitated this is the
reverse of what tends to happen around
adults
here we imagine that people have
deliberately got us in their sights
if someone edges in front of us in the
airport queue it's natural to suppose
that they've sized us up and have reason
that they can safely take advantage of
us
they probably relish the thought of
causing us a little distress
but if we employ the infant model of
interpretation
our first assumptions would be very
different we'd think that maybe they
didn't sleep well that night
have a sore knee or have been upset by
their lover
the french philosopher emilugus chartier
known as allah
was said to be the finest teacher in
france in the first half of the 20th
century
and he developed a formula for calming
himself and his pupils down
in the face of irritating people never
say that people
are evil he wrote you just need to look
for the pin what he meant was look for
the source of the agony that drives a
person to behave in appalling ways
the calming thought is to imagine that
they're suffering off stage
in some area we can't see to be mature
is to learn to imagine this zone of pain
in spite of the lack of much available
evidence
they may not look as if they were
maddened by an inner psychological
ailment
they may seem chirpy and full of
themselves but the pin
simply must be there or they would not
be causing us harm
when others madden us we need to imagine
the turmoil
disappointment worry and sadness beneath
an aggressive surface
we need to aim compassion in an
unexpected place
at those who annoy us most we must do
that very
strange thing move from anger
to pity
you